[Music]
hi my name is peter pomerantzev
i am the author of most recently this is
not propaganda which is a book about
propaganda and it has a unicorn on the
cover which is maybe the best thing
about the book
um i run a little uh sort of think tank
at the london school of economics called
arena
which investigates disinformation
campaigns and and also things about what
we can do to counter them
peter thank you for joining us what
motivated you to write this is not
propaganda
i was trying to work out for myself
actually something something very
personal
i spent the early 2000s in russia seeing
kind of
a propaganda model emerged that was
strikingly
uh strictly different to ones in the
past uh which was based not about
proving the truth but
kind of on seeding doubt and claiming
that facts don't matter
uh there was sort of nostalgia's right
rather than trying to sort of establish
any idea of the future
um and then i came back to sort of
britain
um mid 2010s and then lo and behold 2016
i saw so many of the things i'd seen in
russia in the 2000s in the early 2000s
which already in the late 1990s manifest
themselves here
and and i was just you know full of this
dread deja vu mixture mixture of deja vu
and dread
and i just wanted to understand for
myself why why did the future arrive
first in russia
was i just seeing things was something
systemic going on
and what do we do about it so it really
came from that personal sense of
being weirded out by what was going on
around me um
but you know obviously it's more than a
personal narrative you know i i i
as part of my research at the lse i'm
very into the
question what do we do about what's
known as post-truth politics
so you know the book writing was also a
form of research
as your own analysis evidence and your
own life evidences
this information can be culturally
specific but
speaking more generally how is this
contemporary age of disinformation
different from the propaganda of
previous years sure so look
disinformation let's define that as like
purposefully
false uh information um
so look we've always had that we've
always had propaganda there's nothing
new in that at all
however before political leaders would
try to make their
lies seem like facts you know they're
trying to con us
um if you look at the soviet propaganda
of the late 20th century
uh if you look up the great deception
campaign
the british and the americans you know
they're always trying to take one fake
reality but convince us that that's the
reality
now like trump and putin and and other
leaders
they don't even try to pretend that
their lives are particularly believable
they kind of go oh [ __ ] the facts it's
okay that's cool okay fine
and um that's a slightly different thing
you know that's a slightly different
thing they're not even trying to
convince us
and people accept that i mean this is
not just a one-way street
this is not just like shoving lies in
so people's speak it's also people
accept that and they also seem to like
it
so uh what's changed in us to be able to
accept these kind of characters
i mean why is the fact that boris
johnson lied twice is it once or twice
you know as a journalist lost his job
why is that okay i mean how is even near
the center of our political discourse
why are people ready to accept that the
counter is
yes politicians are lying to us
and yes they're not pretending that
they're not but
are there not ways in which
disinformation now
is less easily discernable than it was
previously
particularly with the rise of technology
particularly with social media those
types of things
so without a doubt there's a technology
factor going on here where
you know we always used to think of
censorship as
you know practice through squeezing the
information space
and now you have political campaigns
kind of flood the zone
with such a mixture of misinformation
soft facts
uh disinformation trolls bots that
people just overwhelmed
and in this world of kind of where
there's just too much information out
there
they kind of retreat into comforting
little emotional pockets and there's a
there is an ideology out there which
these leaders play on the oh the truth
is unknowable it's also confusing
you know bojo might be a liar but like
you know he's fun and cuddly and he
appeals to me
so yeah so there's a bit of that going
on i think as well but again that's not
that's partly there because of the
information space but then that
that sense is also cultivated you know
that the truth is unknowable
that you'll never find the real facts
and the way donald trump always kind of
goes oh well some people are saying you
don't really know
can't really get to the truth uh putin's
been doing that for many years
um cultivating doubt you know rather
than cultivating persuasion as such
so that is definitely a factor and i
think technology
without a doubt is a is a massive factor
of what's going on but i think there are
cultural issues as well
so do people believe the disinformation
that they're being told or are they just
turning a blind eye because it confirms
the narratives that they have an
interest in
it could be a bit of that or i think i
think there's actually a pleasure in
rejecting factual discourse i think
there's a
joy in saying you know bugger off to the
facts uh
you know that there's an anarchic kind
of uh liberation from glum reality
you know the facts aren't very pleasant
you know they tell you that you know the
day that you're gonna die so so what i
think putin and trump
and all the rest of our of our one of
those post-truth politicians
uh tap into is this like you know is
this kind of an arctic release
and also look they're peddling nostalgia
they don't really need factual discourse
to
to
prove nostalgia's nostalgia is why it's
by its nature
you know wispy and ethereal and really
not to do
with any kind of like reality so so you
know factual discourse isn't
particularly profitable for them just as
a
you know as a as a form of narrative
um nostalgia is rooted in kind of vague
emotion
particularly in the developing social
media landscape
how can we discern between what is
targeted
and organized disinformation propaganda
and good faith beliefs of people who may
simply disagree with us
well exactly we can't that's the whole
problem i mean
for all the information we have at the
moment in terms of content
we actually face a different form of
censorship we don't understand how the
material we see especially online is
created we don't decide if something is
you know a confused person or actually a
coordinated mass campaign a cyber
militia or an online mob
that has been designed and created we
have no idea uh so i think
you know that's something that really
has changed and from a regulatory aspect
i think
certain forms of behavior online have
have to become
um regulated and illegal so
uh i think that's something that has to
change we have to be able to tell the
difference whether something is
orchestrated
or that something is genuine how can we
determine which conspiracy theories or
what might be conceptualized does them
merit further investigation
yeah that's it say look you know there's
loads of studies about this that like
you know
everyone has the the conspiracy theory
that confirms their own biases
we see it all the time but still i think
there are communities that you know
even if they slide towards conspiracy
theories because they can feel nice
um you can still just about challenge
them with the facts so you know they
might have
you know you can still engage with them
while others are kind of off the scale
and it's very hard to engage them uh
which conspiracies deserve
you know conspiracy
conspiracies in the terms of a criminal
conspiracy to organize something
happen all the time it's called an
organized you know organized crime
uh conspiracy thinking is the problem
you know when we just start explaining
everything through conspiracies
uh so i think we can make that divide i
mean look at the miller report in the us
it was to find a criminal conspiracy
so i think we'll probably have to
differentiate between the genuine search
for
uh the general search for evidence
which can which is open to factual
challenge
and the belief in the conspiracy that
explains everything which can't be
challenged i think that's probably the
line
can you engage with people and can they
are able to self-criticize their
conspiracy theory or is it just a belief
system
whilst we're talking about them i'm
going to ask your opinion
on a couple of conspiracy theories if
you would want to call them
which are mainstream in popular
contemporary discourse
does putin have an organized plan to
destabilize the west
that's not really conspiracy theory
though uh that's like this who didn't
have a strategy or is he a tactician
that's that question
um look he's the leader of a massive
state
which um will have masses of think tanks
and bureaucrats whose job it is to
produce plan after plan
there will be multiple plans whether
they're following one or the improvising
we don't know
but the russian system is a very
academic kind of system and they will
always have theories and
always have a plan and they'll always
have strategic thinking and they have
massive military and geostrategic
sort of institutions that will produce
plan after plan maybe then puts them in
the bid and goes on going on instinct
uh but no this is it's a highly academic
it's a highly it's a culture where
strategic thinking is a big deal
do you think a foreign power was
responsible for trump's election
or the brexit result
that's kind of a question about media
effects to what extent does an online
campaign
or in america more specifically the
hacking and leaking of the documents
around clinton
to understand is that a linear thing oh
people saw that and voted a certain way
so most scholars of media effects say no
because you should never
their argument is you should never
measure the one percent
you should mention the 99 so fox news
years and years of daily mail articles
are just in terms of methodology much
more significant than a tiny russian
campaign
one cirrus academic disagrees with that
and the problem is she's the most
important academic in this field
catherine hall jameson this is the woman
who
came up with the idea of the echo
chamber back in the 1980s and 90s or the
90s
she's the dwyane of media effects and
she says no that's the wrong methodology
quite the opposite in a situation where
all else is equal
you look at what was the one percent
that changed it so look this all depends
on your methodology and academics just
argue about this ad nauseam
but if you think you know anything about
media effects and you ignore catherine
hall jameson
it's a bit like you know you know it's a
bit like saying like you know you're
into football management but don't think
pep guardiola are serious i mean
she is the best and she created a
language for us
so i would be very careful to dismiss
her in a country like the uk
one in which most of its citizens i'd
like to say
would consider to have a genuine
multi-party democratic system
how does propaganda operate
so we have a new online space
which is completely unregulated so we
had when it comes you know
we knew our system it was very very full
too but it was a weird mix of like
very partisan tabloid media i mean let's
be honest kind of much more right-wing
than left-wing
um bbc trying to balance it all out then
kind of institutions
which were independent who were trusted
whether it was kind of like the offices
of national statistics
to give us information and in this kind
of mess of stuff and we had very clear
electoral rules about what is an
electoral campaign
about how much allowed to spend by no
means was it a perfect system but we had
kind of a rules of the game you know
with
and regulation that kind of try to
organize that
and as a citizen you had at least a
chance of
trying to understand how people were
trying to mess with you online is
completely unregulated we don't know
who's behind what campaign we don't know
really anything about the spend to it
um there's suddenly proxies become much
more of an issue i mean if
you know it's not a political party
doing it you know who is this other
weird organization
there's no understanding why you're
being targeted
uh with with certain material at least
before we could see all the ads
you know they were pretty awful ads very
manipulative we could see all of them
because they were on posters and on tv
now they're dark posts on social media
we don't even know how many different
ads a campaign uses it
so kind of the field within which we can
have a debate about propaganda has
become dark which means we can't
criticize it or engage with it and the
whole kind of
funding has become completely opaque so
we're in this kind of space where
kind of a murky space we don't
understand the forces
that are shaping our information
environment which means we can't have a
debate we can't criticize them
also we can't really tell why we reach
certain decisions
because we don't know what were all the
inputs so that's bad
in the case of as comparable as they can
be superpowers
if all nations are meddling in each
other's affairs
through propaganda campaigns whether
overtly or covertly
does it really matter
so so i don't like this i don't know a
lot of the language that i've heard out
of the u.s about meddling and
interference because that kind of seems
to say at priority
that information flowing across borders
is somehow harmful and i don't think
that's the case sort of thing we still
want a world where inflammation flows
across borders
and where we you know were all involved
in a global village kind of conversation
i think that's fine
uh i think the problem actually is the
deceptive nature of these campaigns so
the problem the russian campaign wasn't
that russia had a campaign in the us
but that you know they were pretending
to be you know people in tennessee
uh you know the russian state saying
look probably can't get involved in
elections per se
but saying look here's what we think of
trump and here's a thing of that
you know that's part of information
across borders so people aren't
particularly
like you know worried about like
nonsense organizations like rt and
sputnik
um what it's the deceptive campaigns
which are the problem
so i would i would draw a very big
distinction between those two things
you bring up rt and then deceptive
campaigns
how deeply does propaganda
propagate the media and those
institutions which are conceived as not
being biased
so i suppose you have to start getting
into the definitions of propaganda i
mean
uh i mean look programming can just be
any type of mass influence which is kind
of fine
uh medical propaganda getting stopped
smoking whatever look there's nothing
absolutely wrong with the russian state
having a tv channel that broadcast
russia's position on staff
you know internationally uh the problem
is that if it's a broadcaster
you know i think broadcasters should be
regulated i think broadcasts do have to
be like big broadcasters
have to be held to levels of of accuracy
and fairness and balance
uh so if they're not doing that and rt
can
are constantly being caught and not
doing that they should you know face
fines or
even more stricter measures uh so i
think that's that's one thing
i think another interpretation of
propaganda is is manipulation and
deception
so you know as long as there's clarity
and transparency about the sources and
the information and why they're doing it
that would let one at least some
principle engage critically
then then i think that's all we need to
demand i'm all for a messy cacophonous
often dirty information space that's
fine but it has to be one that's
interpretable
and the problem at the moment is stop
being interpretable
so how do we make it interpretable well
there's two things a
uh there's a regulatory demand so i
think for online stuff i think do you
think we need to organ
regulate types of behavior online so not
content but behavior so if something is
an orchestrated covert campaign that
should probably go down
that should probably not be allowed to
exist something's an over thing saying
hey we're the russian government we
think this i don't think i think
anyone's really saying that that should
be taken down
uh broadcasting's a bit different
broadcasting has slightly stricter
uh you know demands on the quality of
the content
you know we have regulation in place
already around that it's just a case of
you know
to what extent to what extent it's put
into practice
but that exists i mean that's not a new
idea but the internet
but the internet so yeah so i think it
has to if you look at the russian
campaigns in the u.s so
russian campaigns and britain have
weren't very big until pal actually
uh but in the u.s the problem wasn't the
content some of the content was lies
like you know
hillary clinton is a dragon but most of
it was completely neutral it was just
like you know come on black people don't
vote for hillary it was like voter
suppression
or it was geeing up um trump voters it
was
was strengthening polarization but the
content was often information neutral
what was wrong with it was that it was
deceptive so they were pretending to be
local americans when actually
it was you know yvonne and st petersburg
so that's the problem that it's it's
it's
it's something it's taking something
which is orchestrated
that is inauthentic and it is a campaign
and pretending that it's organic people
that is the problem so how does
disinformation propagate outside of
mass media platforms like the internet
like broadcasting
um well through politicians statements
with
anything else that's by far and away the
biggest one is politicians mainstreaming
this stuff
uh but also you have whispering
campaigns you know there's there's you
know there's been a lot of there's a lot
of
a lot of a lot of tools that you can use
but the internet has definitely turbo
charged stuff so that's where everyone's
focuses now
beyond targeted disinformation campaigns
would you push to make the internet more
transparent
yeah yeah i would i think i think the
targeting campaigns are one
bit of it so i think we have to have
sort of public oversight of algorithms
um i think um
i think we have to know much more about
how our own data is used to target us
so how you know which bits of our own
information is being used
we have to have kind of a 360 degree
vision of all the different types of
messaging that are used even by official
political campaigns
even the ones that identified on a
conservative campaign for the election
you have to see not just the ads
targeted at you online but all the ones
they've done
to see whether it's consistent so a lot
more the whole space has to become
interpretable let's be able to see the
whole means of production
uh of the internet um the targeted
campaigns are
are a part of that but but quite a small
part
do you think that governments and nation
states or private entities
are the primary driving forces of fake
news disinformation
states and who are the other ones nation
states and governments yeah
private entities what's basically aliens
right as opposed to business oh right
right so that's a very interesting one
because something that's not talked
about a lot is how much
of this stuff is used in business uh and
if you think about
like the effects you could have on
business i mean some of these deep fakes
yeah that everyone's worried about like
videos which look real but are fake
you can have a deep fake video they're
pretty easy to debunk by the way deeply
videos you know
so in politics you'd catch it really
really quickly the companies would catch
her
it's just the metadata you can tell
whether it's been manipulated but if you
could just have it says 30 seconds
you know deep fake of a ceo saying oh my
stock market's crap you know my
company's
you know been a pyramid scheme the stock
market will react
so quickly you buy up the stock i mean
it's been debunked 30 seconds later and
you're selling and getting a high one i
mean you could if you're
good at stock market manipulation you
could do so much of this information
and in tiny time frames it would be too
tiny for in politics you know
so the scope for disinformation on this
with financial markets is just
massive and i wonder whether there's a
lot more but we don't hear about it
because all companies are really
embarrassed about it because that makes
them look very unstable
yeah if i was a disinformer i'd be
focusing on that like you know
definitely i bet there's a lot more than
we know about you know
especially like you know campaigns and
ceos and management undermining your
rivals
i think there's going to be a lot there
was actually that's where a lot of this
stuff started with
in ukraine the first troll farms were
created by companies to do smear
campaigns against other companies
so i think that was just a massive thing
but also
i mean what you know nasty civil society
actors so you know you've got
been tracking a lot of disinformation
campaigns
or covert campaigns in europe and sure
it's orban it's putin it's all these
people you'd expect
but then it's like you know far-right
activists who are just coordinating
amongst each other who are quite good at
tech
clearly have got a bit of a background
in marketing doing you know tommy
robinson campaigns and stuff like that
and coordinating
across borders so it's much more
frightening than that it's not just the
states it's also
you know dark civil society actors if
you can call the far-right civil society
actor
terrorist organizations isis excellent
uh
at this sort of stuff so it's a
free-for-all anyone can get involved
how much of our personal data
do the people making these and the
biggest let's say campaigns have
yeah this is this is again we don't know
this is the problem because it's such a
a black hole or uh or a black box and
then whichever whichever
metaphor you want because we don't know
what goes on to take the tech companies
you know there's always this leaks you
know it slowly leaks out facebook like
oh we may have given all your data to
these people and oh they've just
discovered a new one that all these apps
that were connected to facebook i think
we're actually giving data you know to
data brokers
just goes on and on and because we have
no transparency
we just live in an environment where we
can't trust anything anymore
uh and that lack of trust eats away at
kind of the possibilities of a
deliberative democracy so the fact that
i can't answer that question is
is terrible when facebook gives away our
personal data
are they being paid to do so yeah
they're selling honest their business
model
that's the thing that keeps them
operable that's the thing yeah
their business model is sucking up our
data and selling it on that's they're
they're a massive marketing research
exercise so then is it our
responsibility as users to stop using
these platforms
yeah but it's very hard to so in the
philippines for example you're if you
buy a phone
it's hardwired to facebook facebook is
your internet you know you know maybe
here sitting in hampstead we could uh
you know leave facebook for
wicca or something you know like some
sort of you know for some sort of elite
platform that you have to pay for
and you may have more rights but it's
just not that's just not possible for a
lot of people
um a lot of countries facebook is the
model of communication because there's
censorship and actually facebook's quite
useful uh i don't know these companies
have become
i don't like the term public sphere
because it's neither public nor a sphere
but i don't know the common zigzag or
you know that's the role they've ended
up playing
so simply saying you can leave it it's
just not much your possibility in a lot
of places
also other companies come along we're
still left with this challenge
no i think what's broken down is the
border between what is private was
public
you know we have a kind of an agreement
this is our public self it's our private
self
and especially in england we were very
kind of focused on our private self
being private
the social media but it's very nature's
broken that down and what we definitely
need is a new social contract saying
this is the new private and here's the
new public there are other people who
say that
if our data is being used we should be
paid for it you know there's a whole
movement around that
we haven't sorted that out you know we
haven't really defined what are the
terms of engagement
how do you think politics will evolve
through prolonged disinformation
campaigns in the future and what would
you do to avoid
that potential outcome so listen the
problem is the lack of trust it's not so
much the disinformation
as such it's the fact that like we have
to have just enough trust in a democracy
to be able to debate with each other
and to kind of agree okay i lost that
debate you won
that's a consensus you're in power and i
you know that sort of stuff that trump
does that putin feeds that we see kind
of
bubbling through in britain as well is
like oh democracy's rigged you know
because the algorithms are written
because etc etc that you know that
eating away at that social contract
that's incredibly dangerous because it's
a very fractured
it's a very fragile uh
cultural compromise that we trust each
other enough to accept defeat in an
election
um so if that starts to whittle away if
that sense of trust disappears
then um just we just know what happens
in other countries i don't know what's
gonna happen here
uh but in that environment people turn
to strongmen people turn to strong men
who can lead us through this
dark and uh mysterious and murky world
so i don't know what will happen here
specifically i mean britain i think
britain is based on so many social
compromises but you can just see it
fracturing and fracturing and fracturing
scotland drifts off and
this drifts off and you know we just
can't have
a constructive dialogue anymore but
globally it'll be the era of these
bastards
but you know you turn to bastards
because you know compromise is broken
down you need them to deal with things
peter thank you very much for your time
for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute
of art and ideas at iai tv
you